et vous aimeriez mourir comment
on va faire un Richard Anconina on va
faire un art diviou et vous connaissez
vous aussi puisque vous êtes là Laeticia
vous savez qu'on ne savait ça ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle vous savez ce qui
est formidable
on ne bouge
pas ça c'est formidable c'est énorme
vous êtes prêts
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
j'enlève mes lunettes parce que je
regarde et je lis je puis j'enlève mes
lunettes
quand vous voyez dans la glace
sinon je vois pas c'est la première
chose que je vais vous changeriez quoi
en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
vous concernant vous changeriez quoi si
vous aviez une baguette magique
comme ça je sais me servir de moi comme
ça
quand vous étiez petit vous ressembler à
qui
les physiques que j'adorais
Gary Cooper
[Musique]
je suis pas mauvaise
quelle est la quelle est la phrase que
vous ne supportez pas d'entendre
la phrase je sais pas c'est
pas faim le propos pessimiste je le
voilà une phrase en tête mais c'est le
propos pessimiste on va pas y arriver
quoi
je supporte ça vous préférez draguer ou
faire draguer la notion de draguer je
ne connais pas et je ne la reconnais pas
et comment vous faites
une question de rencontre de personnes
je sais pas quoi de de chasseur et de
dragueur de de stratégie et depuis l'âge
de préférez séduire sans rien faire
si je dois séduire tant mieux vous
préférez larguer ou faire larguer
j'ai déjà été quitté c'est
quand on est très amoureux c'est très
dur non c'est toujours assez confortable
d'être largué parce qu'on est un petit
peu martyr et puis ça donne des forces
et puis je sais pas
c'est toujours plus je préfère souffrir
que de faire souffrir en fait
vous avez pleuré quand pour une femme
pour la dernière fois
je pense que j'ai pleuré pour une femme
mais il
y a 83
83 ça va
il y a 17 ans ça va
et que c'est une histoire d'amour qui
s'est arrêtée c'était il y a 17 ans
qu'est-ce que les femmes préfèrent chez
vous
Laetitia vous préférez quoi les yeux les
humains comme ça un peu on a envie de
s'occuper de lui non
c'est pas près méditer j'ai
pris une fille au hasard je suis tombé
j'ai vraiment la main verte
si vous restez 24 heures à vivre vous
feriez quoi
je sais pas je regarde la mer ah ouais
tout seul non mais je sais pas
je vivrai je sais pas j'en sais rien
et vous aimeriez mourir comment vite
vous préféreriez être enterré ou
incinérer c'est sympa c'est mission
c'est une émission du samedi soir c'est
gay
incinéré ou enterré
es
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu